proprietor active is known for making
like really heavy simulation games such
as Red Orchestra but five years ago they
came out with killing floor one which is
like a horde based game where you're
using ridiculous guns to kill a bunch of
zombies and they've been supporting that
game ever since but we finally got a
chance to play Killing Floor 2 and are
you were really excited shooting for one
like they've been supporting it for so
long that if you you know dropped it
five years ago cuz you would rather play
left 4 dead right because they were kind
of competing at the time I don't blame
you but they've actually like up kept it
and it plays super well even to this day
so I was surprised that as soon as I got
my hands on Killing Floor 2 about the
jumping quality even that has over the
personal and its plays super well the
shooting is great it's still killing for
though that's the thing I could still
look at the same game just like amped up
to another level
it's a very simple experience but
they've done a really good job of
creating you know a large group of
monsters and a large variety of weapons
that kind of make the experience you
know remain interesting over a long
period of time and have you played for a
couple hours and it's just the
difficulty kept Ram tank ramping up and
you know at the same time I was thinking
this game isn't that complicated it's
very simple but it's executed in a way
that's just really clean and precise so
it doesn't need to be this grand
experience right it's just like a pure
horde mode shooter that's just for fun
for the fun of shooting that's the thing
that's the tripwire does best the fun of
shooting is exactly what they might just
drive for because all their guns are
like super well modeled and like the way
the shoe is just like super satisfying
and it's so fun to try out as many guns
as you can because you go to the trader
in between rounds and find new stuff and
in this one they have like future
weapons correct like kind of and those
are really cool because I've never seen
tripwire do see them do World War two I
haven't seen them do like what they
think the future kind of for a
submachine gun is gonna feel like and it
was pretty [ __ ] cool
I saw you using the I was a would even
called a gun the Visser ATAR it had like
a saw blade on the front of it but they
can actually fire anything yeah it did
so it was like a chainsaw they used gas
to spin the blade but then I also had a
magazine of blades that you could really
love and it they would go out and then
you can actually pick them up later well
yeah that gun was like my top tier for
my perk I don't want to go into all that
like part system cuz there's just so
many of there's so many they're not
showing right now because this game is
coming out on the 21st on early access
as it is as we played it so they're just
gonna get lots of feedback before they
start like you know fixing up all the
other person stuff like that huh it
certainly is like a game you can jump in
and jump out so often and and they're
gonna keep supporting it probably you
know based on their track record for so
long the game forever
exactly somebody must be playing killing
for one to this day for them to justify
it making new maps and weapons overtime
so you got to imagine that audience is
ready for the jump to the new one if it
is that much better like you say and
having I didn't play the first one but I
saw a bunch of videos and they've
definitely made a big leap when it comes
to presentation and I just think the
overall I hate to use this word of a
polish here to the game you know it's
maybe it was a little clunky before but
now it seems so smooth and that wouldn't
be surprising to see them support this
for the next few years and you're
absolutely right like there's way better
lighting in the levels you can shoot the
lighting out so it like changes the time
so the battlefield there's just gore
everywhere that stays like the details
and the juices of the bodies just stay
in the environment which is cool with
nice touch so yeah everything's just
been brought up to that next level
polish